صباح الخير لكل متابعي صباح العربيه ضيفت
اليوم هي قليله الاطلالات ولكن عندما
نتحدث عن نجمات مصر هي دائما على راس
القائمه ضيفه اليوم هي الممثله المصريه
العربيه نيللي كريم اللي راح تكون وياي في
هذا اللقاء القصير في لوس انجلوس ابقوا
معي سعيد جدا بهذا اللقاء اليوم ونورتي
لوس انجلوس بوجودك مستمتع هنا
مستمتعه جدا بلد جميله اول مره اجي هنا
يعني مش حاسه نفسي غريبه ان هي بلد انترنت
عشان
الميكروفون فيها جنسيات كتير
بالوطن العربيه
ده ما بتبقاش كده هو دايما الواحد بيستنى
العمل
المناسب او يبقى عمل يضيف له لكن اللي مش
مجرد يطلع يعمل اي عمل بره فاهم اا لما
يبقى في موضوع حلو يبقى موضوع انترناشونال
ان سبرت مهرجانات كثير يعني رحت مهرجان
كان ومهرجان فانوس وكنت في لجنه التحكيم
في مهرجان فانوس اا
على فكره ممكن تطلع من بلدك للعالميه برده
يعني ده شيء وارد بس مع فيلم كويس مع
موضوع مهم موضوع انترناشونال ما يبقاش
موضوع لوكال بس لكن يبقى موضوع يخص همم
العالم كله
بيتكلم عن التحرش وده موضوع انترنت
في بلاد كثير جدا
[ضحك]
اا بعد رمضان عشان كل واحد عنده مسلسل
اااه فيلم انساني جدا على زيرو في ال- اا
بيتكلم عن اب اا ابنه بيمرض مرض وحش
وظروفه الماديه همم عزيرو على الزيرو
ظروفه الماديه همم وحشه جدا فبيعمل كل
حاجه في سبيل ان هو ينقذ ابنه
كريم
مسلسل صعيدي
اول مره يمكن اعمل الصعيدي لان اللغه
الصعيديه لغه
حلوه جدا ولكن صعبه صعبه في نفس الوقت
طبعا هشام موجود خلف الكاميرا حضر نفسك
لازم تشاركنا بعدين بالمنزل
[ضحك]
لا بص البتاع ده انا هاقول الحقيقه انا من
ساعه ما اتجوزه صح انت اختي مرتين ههه
موضوع ثاني ههه
تقول عليها ايه
احنا بنخبرنا على مالك المستقبليه شنو جاي
تشتغل بالوقت الحالي والله بصوا انا شغال
دلوقتي احنا لسه مخلصين روز وليله حبيبي
بيتهيالي هيبقى ظريف جدا دمه خفيف يعني
حاجه اسره
دي هتبقى حاجه ظريفه جدا ومخرج كان
انجليزي وكاتب انجليزي هيطلع شكل مختلف
جدا متصور بطريقه مختلفه همم
كوميدي وعندنا حاجه ان شاء الله صعيدي
باذن الله في رمضان هل ممكن نشوفكم بيعمل
المشترك انتم الاثنين كل حاجه بيبقى لها
وقت مناسب وكل حاجه بيبقى لها الموضوع
يعني انا دائما بادور على همم
انا يعني في ناس مثلا بتدور على دور
فانا بدور على الموضوع كله على بعضه
بيتكلم عن ايه همم
هيضفلي هل انا هاضيف له
فدي حاجات مهمه قوي همم والله انا يعني في
كم مشروع همم انا وهشام معروضين علينا بس
احنا ماجلين لهم ماجلين لهم شويه
عامل حاجات كثيره جدا جدا جدا فاهم مش
هتعمل حاجه دلوقت وبالذات يعني ده قرار
يعني الفتره اللي فاتت اخذناه انا مش
هنعمل حاجه غير لما يكون خلاص بقى حاجه
هتضيف حاجه نفسها تعملها حاجه نفسها تطلع
فيها فلو الموضوع مظبوط حلو وحاجه هي
شايفاها جديده ياريت اخذ رايك
التغيير الي بصير بالسعوديه وتطور شنو
رايك بالتغيرات
في حاجات جديده على مستوى الفني كمان همم
اعمال كثير جدا بتتعمل وعجبني الكوليبريشن
ان همم
مهتمين بالسينما مهتمين بالطلبيشن بس
بيجيبوا الكروت لاقي فيه مصريين وفي
تلاقيه جنسيات ثانيه في كمان بيشتغلوا مع
امريكان مع ابليز فبتلاقي الكلوبريشن دي
بتطلع حاجات حلوه دائما
[موسيقى]
كل بني ادم يعني مش هنتكلم حتى
في حياته همم
لازم يبقى يعرف يقف الوقفه دي اللي نفسه
هو
دي حاجه الوحيده اللي هتوقفوا على رجله
الوقت لازم اختم ايش حابه تقولي لي كل
المتابعين اللي بده يتابعونا من خلال صباح
العربيه وبعدين اكيد انتقل مع هشام صباح
العربيه عايزه اقول لكم صباح العربيه ههه
باحب صباح العربيه جدا باتفرج عليه دائما
خصوصا لما ببقى في السفر بصراحه همم
كل حاجه جديده او اللي بيحصل في الوطن
العربي
العربيه والله طبعا هي صباح العربيه مش
محتاجه ان انا اتكلم عنها الناس كلها
عارفه طبعا يعني هي حاجه كبيره جدا
وطبعا اكتر حاجه عجباني يعني دلوقت حالا
يعني الشياكه ههه
بعيني اللي شافونا وعوده الى الاستديو
[موسيقى]